[Music]
is there a chance dick grayson could
soon be making his way to the world of
the batman what hint did the movie drop
that implied he could keep watching to
find out about this comics easter egg
director matt reeves as the batman
delivers a brand new version of the
caped crusader to the big screen sure dc
fans are incredibly familiar with bruce
wayne's origin after seeing it several
times in animation and live action but
this is a much darker film that takes a
precise look at the tortured vigilante a
couple of years into his crime fighting
career
the film has already been a huge hit
with critics daily star's andy lee calls
it a gritty pacy and achingly stylish
adventure while the digital fixes tom
percival says it's surprisingly hopeful
it's fair to say that this new take on
gotham city does feel grimier than
previous iterations of the bat's home
turf
it's stylistically similar to the world
of david fincher's seven with hints of
zodiac in there for good measure this
largely stems from paul dano's haunting
depiction of the riddler as a terrifying
serial killer who takes aim at the
corrupt gotham elite
thankfully robert pattinson's bruce
isn't alone in his mission to serve
justice on city streets he's also joined
by anti-hero catwoman played by zoe
kravitz and police lieutenant james
gordon played by jeffrey wright the film
isn't crammed with easter eggs like
other comic book movies that dominate
the box office but there are a few
carefully placed references to classic
dc characters the plot itself takes cues
from classic batman storylines such as
year one the long halloween and zero
year but there's also a surprising nod
to one of the most famous members of the
bat family nightwing by the end of the
batman catwoman aka selena kyle decides
that it's time for her to leave gotham
for a while it's an understandable move
because part of her arc revolves around
finding who killed her best friend
annika and why
to make matters worse selena is forced
to confront the fact that she's the
illegitimate daughter of mobster carmine
falcone he abandoned celina's mother
after their brief fling and she was
forced to grow up in poverty as a result
falcone meanwhile only grew more
powerful
so after she helps batman stop the
riddler's plan she tells the dark knight
she might head to bloodhaven that's a
loaded reference for comics readers
bloodhaven is a city not too far from
gotham it's also where dick grayson who
became nightwing after being robin moves
in the comics when he starts to forge
his own identity away from batman
pranks jokes and tomfoolery have no
place here and my identity must reflect
that from this day forward
call me nightwing as he soon finds out
bloodhaven is an incredibly violent
place and there aren't any superheroes
operating there because of how ruthless
the villains are nightwing is the one
who makes a stand when bruce asks him to
investigate a string of deaths in 1996's
nightwing issue number one it's not
enough for dick just to patrol the
streets at night though as he needs
reliable intelligence to take down
gangsters like blockbuster even ends up
becoming a police officer by day while
it's entirely possible that reeves and
his co-writer peter craig will introduce
dick grayson further down the line the
bloodhaven reference probably isn't a
hint that nightwing will show up in the
batman 2. even if they introduce grayson
in the sequel he'll probably start off
as robin to explore that dynamic with
batman rather than stepping into his
nightwing persona straight away
name-dropping bloodhaven is more likely
just a bit of world building however
that's not to say nightwing won't make
the leap to the big screen eventually
warner brothers picked the tomorrow war
director chris mckay to helm a solo
movie for the hero in the dc extended
universe when speaking to den of geek
back in 2021 mckay said he still wants
to work on the project i hope that we
get a chance to go out and make that
dick grace in a nightwing film a
particular part of robin growing from
being under batman to becoming nightwing
and bloodhaven and all that stuff it's a
really personal story to me for
nightwing fans desperate to see the hero
in live action at least hbo max's titans
will scratch that itch brenton thwaites
plays a version of the hero that's
become a real fan favorite and it's not
hard to see why
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]